let me return to yuri bismanov who was a
soviet kgb agent that wrote a four-step
framework for ideological subversion on
a national scale as practiced by the
soviet union so
the the four
steps are demoralization destabilization
crisis and normalization he had a lot of
other kind of
systematic ways of describing this kind
of stuff so
can you speak to some of these ideas
about the systematic large-scale
ideological subversion goals of the kgb
is there truth to that kind of
those ideas yes but um
i
i think i already sort of mentioned that
i think bessmanov was a fraud
and i have i have again
can you elaborate good arguments let's
put it this way
uh first of all uh we we know that uh
the kgb was involved in active measures
which is
you know um
you can call it uh
fake news
yeah uh seeding fake news into the
advert in the countries that are your
adversaries
and and the russians have been doing
this uh lately by meddling in our
election and
and focusing on the left and the right
fringe and influencing them to become
more left and no more right so that and
uh and vasily mctroken
uh
has and has in in one of his books uh he
has a whole chapter about active
measures
okay so what he has to say about the
department and i forgot what department
that was
was the one department that was the
least desirable
for kgb agents because these were desk
jobs
for people
who had to come up with
fake stories
that uh in countries where they didn't
quite know
too much about the country
now there were some successes
like one of them
the two
most famous successes
that i'm aware of is that uh
the canard that the aids virus was
concocted in a cia lab
and so a lot of people around the world
believe that
and the other one was that
j edgar hoover was a secret
cross-dresser
cross-dresser
that was that that is still known by a
lot of americans who are of a certain
age that this was the truth but
mitrokin actually traces it back to
a story that was placed in a
sort of left wing but
close to mainstream
uh french magazine and it was then taken
taken up by
uh more
you know
larger
newspapers and and well-established
papers
so so they had some successes but this
kind of a
um
massive
well
thought out
campaign to destabilize the united
states i don't believe the kgb was
capable of doing that
mitrokina seems to agree with me
i was trained
i would think
you know i was one of the crown jewels
of their agents
one would think that they used the best
that they had to to help me
how to
become an american and they didn't have
a clue
so how did they cut if you don't know
how a country operates how do you come
up with with this this this this kind of
a very detailed uh long-term plan that's
that's also timed you know two years
this and one year that and all that yeah
so we should
actually just clarify so he he has this
whole idea
that there's a 15 to 20 years i need it
for demoralization
where you're
you're basically infiltrating a country
from a young or people from a young age
manipulating their mind you're
destabilizing them that's the second
step that takes two to five years
you uh target the country's foreign
relations defense and economy you create
a crisis artificially and then you
normalize it as as if it always was this
way so it's basically saying
that the kgb is capable of at scale
over many
years manipulate an entire population of
people
right and this is kind of
um
there's a lot of
people that believe in conspiracy
theories that
are amenable to this kind of idea
now my own experience
is that there is in fact just a giant
amount of incompetence and this is
something that's actually very difficult
to pull off because yes it's incredibly
um
incredibly difficult to achieve this
kind of manipulation i think it would it
would require
first of all not much bureaucracy not
much slowing down you have to have
incredible so in the modern world
digital systems are able to do
surveillance manipulation there has to
be a strategy that is carried out in
secrecy across a huge number of people
effectively that also requires you to
hire the best people in the world
and i think it's difficult to execute on
this kind of thing
with the
if you compartmentalize
because there has to be great
collaboration there has to be a great
work where there's a unified vision
coordination
and coordination across
multiple groups there has to be i mean
that it's very difficult to do now
nevertheless especially with technology
this becomes easier and easier so the
bar
goes lower and lower to achieve
mass surveillance becomes easier and
easier and easier uh mass manipulation
through platforms because we're now
digitally connected you can now do that
kind of manipulation so it becomes more
and more realistic that you could do
this kind of thing but
uh you're saying that no intelligence
first of all intelligence is hard
and to do it at scale and to do it well
and to do it
um in a way that it's also
not just collecting information about
the populace but manipulating the
populace is very very difficult right
now let me give you an another argument
why i think that bes minor was a fraud
uh yeah i mean i already have i i have
uh uh matrokin on my side and and my
personal observation of uh the
incompetence
that uh that i witnessed i mean they
really really didn't know what they
didn't know so now bezmanov was kgb
where was he stationed
in india
he he was a
low-level
agent in india
and i told you with the one thing that
the kgb was really good was
that it was compartmentalization how
does bezna besmanov in india find out
about this massive plan that should have
been super secret right
he made it up sorry yeah and and you
know why he got away with it because
americans eat that up because it's not
our fault it's like the damn russians
that don't do doing all that that bad
stuff speaking of the damn russians
doing all that bad stuff
you know about the internet research
agency
they have been doing quite a bit of
damage and uh
uh i i'm now familiar with the world of
uh
enhanced artificial persons these are
the avatars
on facebook and twitter and you know
so forth that uh look like real people
and uh and uh and there are quite a few
of them and and i have a good friend who
operates in in that realm
and uh you know he he uses for instance
facial recognition when he
uh
uh
thinks that
there's a suspicious character say on
linkedin or or on facebook
and very often he finds out yeah that
that person exists but it's not the
person who
it pretends to be
so basically detecting the artificial
yes enhanced artificial yes but but he
can also make them
you know you think the united stand in
hand yeah the united states doesn't do
it we do it too but uh well this is to
push back against your pushback right
yeah bezmanov might be a fraud
but is it possible especially in the
modern age that there is these kind of
large-scale systematic operation
wouldn't you
as a government more so uh that's
investing billions of dollars into
military
equipment
um in in a world that's
more and more clearly going to be
defined by
cyber war versus
hot war right wouldn't you
start to have serious meetings
large amounts of hires
that are working at how do we manipulate
the information flow how do we
manipulate the minds of the populace how
do we sell them a narrative
so even though he might have been making
up a story because people eat it up
could it speak to some deep truth that's
actually different than the the truth
you came up in as a kgb agent oh i agree
with you 100 is much easier when uh you
know all you need is is an army of nerds
who also know that's
no faster than nervousness that's a term
of endearment yes i love love i love
nerds
i i used to be one myself
but anyways i was a nerd so you know
um
so what i was gonna say here is all you
need is an army of nerds and and what
but also
uh
experts in the culture of the target
country okay and and nowadays the world
is different there's a whole lot more
fluidity there's a whole lot of more
people that like say russians for
instance study in the united states
chinese an army of chinese studying in
the united states they
they have a lot more knowledge of how we
function than the kgb did
and it's vice versa uh not as many
americans in in russia but we have some
but
the the chinese and the russians have an
advantage here
you